hello and welcome to the latest s
bioscience webinar in our webinar series
my name is tim mcalhan and i am global
product manager at essen bioscience
it's really great to see that we have
such a large audience from all over the
world today
today's webinar will be 35 minutes long
after which we will have a brief q and a
session and provide access to the slides
used in the
presentation today so without further
ado it is my pleasure to introduce our
speaker today
del trazais who is co-founder and
director of the sm bioscience labs in
europe
dell the floor is yours okay hello
everybody
wherever you may be um thank you for the
introduction
tim and thank you for everybody who's
dialed in for today's webinar
the title of the presentation is as
hopefully you can see on the slide smart
cell monitoring
resolving the changing needs of cellular
research with continuous
live cell analysis
so the structure of the webinar is as
follows
to begin with i will overview some of
the fundamental challenges that we face
in biomedical research and then discuss
the changing landscape of cell models
and cell systems that we use
i'll then go on to introduce continuous
life cell
analysis as a concept and as a method
and then describe some of the current
and emerging technologies
which are bringing this method to
the everyday researcher i'll then spend
some time
illustrating the application of
continuous lyocell analysis in some
worked examples before wrapping up and
providing a perspective on the future
okay so the fundamental challenges in
biomedical research that we face there
probably isn't a day that goes by where
we shouldn't be thinking
whether we're doing in vivo models or in
vitro work
how relevant and translational the model
systems that we are using
to the things that we're trying to
understand how relevant
are they how reliably do they inform us
and are they truly predictive and
translational
all big questions secondarily
over the years and largely through the
input of
the science of genetics and epigenetics
and studies on the environment
it's increasingly clear that patients
are
ever more complex than perhaps we
had originally imagined they are unique
and their biology changes over time so
anything that we
understand or um
can measure from a a patient
is only ever true at that particular
point in time
and that their biology will change and
is dynamic as they age
so these are two of the fundamental
challenges that we
need to consider
on this next slide i've tried to capture
some of the
major applications of uh cells in
biomedical research
within this the context of these
fundamental challenges so
in the top left hand corner basic
mechanisms of
biology understanding signaling pathways
in cells
understanding how cells join together to
form tissues
understanding how tissues form together
to form organs and and
whole beings in the top right hand
corner
using cells to try to predict the
efficacy and safety of potential new
thera
therapies um do we see in those cell
models
uh what we will ultimately see when we
take those
potential new medicines to our patient
population
in the bottom left-hand corner
bio-manufacture cells are very good
at making certain biologicals for
example
antibodies and fourthly the science of
cell therapy has moved on tremendously
over the last
decade so cells can
be considered as therapeutics in their
own right
okay so this slide captures
what i'll refer to as the changing
landscape of the use of cellular models
it's illustrative and shows on the
x-axis
how increasingly researchers are moving
towards
more relevant cell types in their
research whether those are primary cells
or stem cell derived cells or even
patient specific cells
and organized in them in more relevant
ways shown here on the y-axis so moving
from simple two-dimension-dimensional
monocultures towards co-cultures
and three-dimensional micro tissues and
indeed organs on a chip so
this this landscape is moved
towards more advanced cell systems in
their research
now these new or newer advanced cell
systems
certainly present some great opportunity
for translational research but they also
present some different challenges
compared to working with immortalized
cell lines or tumor cell lines
as a generalization they're typically
harder to source
and to to maintain they're often of a
limited supply
some of the cells are expensive to
purchase and they are more challenging
to work with the um
exemplification of this would be for any
of you working with cho
cells or hex cells or healer cells you
probably get to the end of your working
week and you throw away
unused cells you discard them they're
low cost and
you don't worry too much about that i
suspect for those of you working with
human stem cell derived neurons for
example
you're not throwing away cells as a
matter of course because they're
expensive
and they're precious to you and you're
trying to extract the most information
that you
can from them secondarily again compared
to mortalized cells
these advanced cell systems uh typically
more
dynamic the properties of the cells
change more over time some of the cells
are eliminated
lifespan cells will differentiate
de-differentiate
and in the way that people are
organizing them to take advantage of our
understanding of the importance of the
micro environment for example
cell to cell communication is is
something which is more
prevalent and interesting in these
advanced cell models compared to
immortalized cells
this next slide really really
recapitulates what i just told you
so i won't spend too long on it but it's
a basic scoring of some of the high
level attributes
of different cell model system so that
the top row are
host cell cell lines as the the most
reductionist and simple
and at the bottom micro tissues and
organoids and
as i mentioned if you consider the
relative cost
ease of use and availability um
there is certainly a trade-off in
working with these advanced cell models
so
the experiment we're all part of is this
search for greater translational
relevance
but the quid pro quo is that these new
cell models
are more challenging to work with
they're typically more costly
and certain cell types have a limited
availability
uh which which forces the the needs to
do what i'm going to refer to as
economic experiments
okay so working with these advanced cell
models
um presents some new requirements for
analytical methods so it stands to
reason that if you're going to take the
time and efforts to work with advanced
cell models
that your analytical methods should be
commensurate with those so you don't
want to be taking
really simplistic or or low value
measurements from an advanced cell model
that doesn't really make too much sense
secondarily given the dynamic nature of
these advanced cell models
analytical methods that contract
parameters over time and allow
biologists to understand temporal
changes will be
ever more valuable thirdly
given that these cells are precious any
methods that are cells sparing whether
that be through
true assay miniaturization or
potentially through streamlined
workflows where you just don't use as
many cells you just don't waste as many
sales you don't need as many sales for
assay development
and assay optimization those methods
will also be
favored and finally you really want your
analytical methods to be sufficiently
user-friendly that you can use them to
focus on the complexities in the biology
rather than focusing on the complexities
of the analytical method in its own
right
so with all that in mind continuous
monitoring
and analysis as a method is ideally
suited to meeting these needs presented
by advanced cell models
and that will be the topic for the
next section of this webinar
now just before we do that um we just uh
like to take a short break
and on your screen we'll pop up a
question that would like you to consider
are you using an advanced cell system as
we've defined here
if you wouldn't mind just giving us a
quick yes or no answer
we'll just spend a few seconds on this
and then we'll move on to the next part
of the webinar
okay thank you very much so section two
continuous monitoring and analysis so
i'm aware that many of you will already
understand and appreciate what we refer
to but for those
that for those of you that this may be
new to i'd like to start by
presenting an analogy to another health
care situation um to really illustrate
what we mean by continuous monitoring
and analysis
so if we consider how traditionally
healthcare checks have been done it's
been done by
visits to your general practitioner who
will measure your for example
cardiovascular parameters let's take
heart rate as an example
you will have an appointment your gp
will measure
your heart rate hopefully it's within
range
they will send you away and say come
back in six months time and then you'll
come back and
they'll make the same measurement and
determine whether it's gone up down or
stayed the same
um in the modern world with the
developments of new technology and the
illustration here is of a fitbit
wearable technology monitor
you can continuously measure your heart
rate you don't need a general
practitioner to help you
now in the two scenarios uh shown here
by
a and b in scenario one the uh
the parameter does change as a function
of time it generally you know
oscillates above and below a a straight
line here there may be days where you've
dropped too much coffee or had a
stressful day at work where
the parameter is slightly higher and
then and
conversely it may be slightly lower than
the average on on a more relaxed moment
however if your continuous measurement
looks more like line b
you probably should be concerned where
there's this trend for
your heart rate to increase in time and
you really should be going to see
an expert to get some more detailed uh
analysis time
hopefully it's clear from this example
the benefits of this continuous
monitoring are firstly more accurate
baseline
secondly the ability to do to determine
or detect
trends and outliers in the data set
and you can use that early detection to
make an early decision you wouldn't wait
for six months to go see your gdp if
your trend was
for a raising a rising parameter
importantly the detection method in this
case the fitbit monitor
is very non-perturbing to the biology of
interest so
both your lifestyle you don't need to
take your day off work to go and see
your general practitioner
and secondary this is important what we
refer to as the white coat syndrome
it's inherently anxiety inducing going
into an unfamiliar environment to have
your cv parameters monitored whereas
your fitbit you can just wear it day and
night and it's completely unperturbing
to
uh to the measurement itself ultimately
this
approach should be uh simpler and
cheaper too
now i don't want anybody to take this as
a well visit to your general
practitioner is no longer required
but hopefully you get the point that the
value of continuous monitoring
provides something different and useful
to
these snapshot measurements
okay so applying that similar logic to
live cell analysis so continuous live
cell analysis what is it
well put simply it's the continuous or
semi-continuous
measurement of parameters in cells so
these can be
relevant or should be relevant analyses
in real time
so there may be things like cell
function measurements or morphology
measurements or phenotype measurements
the measurements should be made from
completely non-perturbed living cells
in which case the environmental control
of those cells
is imperative thirdly the measurement
should be non-exhaustive so you don't
want to be depleting your cells each
time you make a measurement from them
if the biology of interest unfolds over
hours days or weeks then your continuous
live cell analysis approach
should be able to follow that long-term
biology
and finally the liar cell analysis
approach should be applicable across
many workflows so not just for
the types of kinetic assays that you may
think about but also
throughout the husbandry of the cells
and any manipulations to the cells that
you may make
okay so just thinking about that that
kind of continuum of cell culture
cell manipulation and phenotypic assay
i've tried to list on this slide a few
of the workflow applications
where continuous live cell analysis adds
value
i won't go through them one by one but
they're clustered as
cell culture activities cell
manipulation
activities for example stem cell
reprogramming or clone dilution
and cell assay activities
you know starting from quality control
and cell plating
through the detail mechanism of action
studies
to loop back to the analogy i drew
earlier just to illustrate how this
differs from
traditional endpoint measurements so for
those of you making
end point uh measurements with plate
readers
for the most part it seems probable that
the first
true measurement that you make from your
cells is a single time slice
at the assay uh part of this continuum
you don't you don't make measurements
through the cultural manipulation phases
whereas with continuous liars cell
monitoring you have the
opportunity to derive parameters on cell
health and morphology and growth
through your cell husbandry activities
you can understand the efficiency of
transfection if you're introducing new
genes for example
you can verify the consistency of
plating if you're using microtiter
plates for your assays
and the effects of any pre-treatments
before you get into the kinetic assay
itself where you can follow the
full-time course of the biology
and not have to worry about which
particular time point may be most
relevant for your measurements of
interest
okay so i want to move on now to
introduce a couple of the
technical approaches which are used
for continuous lifestyle analysis the
first is electrical measurements
so there are a number of systems out
there now that
allow researchers to measure impedance
or extracellular field potentials from
cells
these methods can be used by systems
that reside within a standard cell
incubator providing the essential
environmental control
they do require specialist electro
plates in order to
resolve the signals but the signals are
non-invasive
they're label-free and they can be
applied repeatedly and over the long
term
in my view the most relevant
and value adding applications for the
electrical
uh technologies are for measuring things
from excitable cells so neurons and
cardiomyocytes
however impedance uh is also a surrogate
for a number of other cellular
phenotypes such as cell migration
cell proliferation cell adhesion and
others and has been used in that way
um some of the downsides or the
challenges with the electrical approach
are that the impedance signals
can be difficult to interpret because
they do translate to so many different
cellular phenotypes
in some cases rather high cell numbers
are
required in order to make robust
impedance measurements which is
somewhat of a downside compared to
premise for cell sparing requirements
for the advanced cell models
and finally some of the electroplate
consumables can be reasonably
reasonably costly i've shown two
examples on the right hand side of this
slide so just to talk about those very
briefly so the top right hand panel
shows some
cellular impedance measurements over a
three day period of a549 cells
plated onto these electrode plates
during the first 24 hours
the impedance increases as the cells
adhere to the plate
and then different groups overlaid here
are treated with different cytotoxic
compounds
and you can see that some prevent the
increase
in impedance that's associated with
proliferation of the cells so this is a
quasi-cell proliferation cytotoxicity
assay the lower panel shows some
measurements of from a multi-electrode
array extracellular fuel potentials in
mouse spinal cord
and during the first couple of weeks of
these cultures you don't
detect much electrical activity
in this paradigm but if you leave the
cells long enough they will start to
communicate
with each other and using extracellular
fuel potentials you can start
to measure these synaptic evoked
action potentials in these spinal cord
neurons and you can do this for
weeks and weeks on end using the
appropriate technology
okay so that's the electrical approach
let's now
talk about the imaging approach um
so again this will hopefully be obvious
to many but
uh the this approach involves taking
time-lapse images of cells
using imaging devices or microscope
systems
that are housed within environmentally
controlled
chambers in order to keep the cells
happy and healthy
you can make label free measurements
from cells using phase contrast of right
field microscopy
or you can use non-perturbing
fluorescent probes
in order to measure other parameters
from cells which i'll come and talk more
about in a moment
as i mentioned these devices are
designed to work
within the humidified and warm
environment of a
cell incubator therefore keeping the
cells happy
but in comparison to the electrical
devices you don't need
specialized consumables you can do this
with regular tissue culture
plastic applications are numerous
ranging from cell health
through to cell quality control and
advanced phenotypic
assays and a final important point
on here is that these types of imaging
systems
do not require particularly large
numbers of cells
so they are very well aligned to some of
the requirements of the advanced cell
models
that i mentioned
okay um so on this table i've tried to
capture
some of the different types of live cell
analysis
imaging solutions i've clustered them
into four types contact microscopes live
cell images
dedicated to this microscope
workstations
and high content images the compact
microscopes and live cell images work
within a standard cell incubator
the workstations typically have their
own housing for
environmental control and the high
content imaging devices
typically have bolt-on stages which in
fairness are not particularly good at
long
term uh cell stability they're okay for
one or two days but much beyond that
they're less less good the compact
microscopes are typically of lower costs
but the consequences they have less
flexibility in the optical systems
and lower capacity and throughput and
and little in the way of automated
analysis
image analysis tools the dedicated life
cell images as you would expect they're
targeted towards this application so
they
have a fairly balanced perspective in
terms of throughput capacity
automated analysis and flexibility
it may surprise you the capacity through
put scoring on the high content imager
here
uh just to point that out that's with
regards to use for continuous
continuous analysis high content readers
are very good
for single endpoint analysis but bearing
in mind they can only read one plate
at a time if you want to continuously
analyze from cells
then their overall capacity is fairly
low
okay so just before we go on to the
third section of the webinar we have
another question that would ask i'd like
you to
think about for a moment so the question
is
on your screen are you currently
performing any continuous or real-time
lifestyle analyses
in your research just give you a few
moments to think about that
okay thank you very much so let's come
on to some examples
and uh hopefully this is where it will
all fall into place so
the first example i'd like to talk about
with regards to the the application and
the value
of continuous lifestyle analysis is a
project in which we were looking
to differentiate human cortical neural
stem cells
and develop long-term stable neural
networks in order to do pharmacological
studies upon so to explain the
graph on the left this is a time course
of the development of neurites in these
cultures
over an eight day period we use neurite
length
as a marker for the differentiation into
the neuronal phenotype and then
subsequently obviously as a
an index of the neural network
we took these uh cells cryopreserve
cells
we placed them onto wells in a 96 volt
plate and started to measure new right
length and for the first 24 hours or so
there were little or no neurites in
these cultures as you would expect
these were not differentiated these are
precursor cells
after 24 hours we added an exogenous
differentiation stimulus and then we
monitored
for the next four or five days the
development
of these neurites and lo and behold we
saw
each each line represents data from the
single well
we saw this consistent development of
neurites and this differentiation
of the precursors into mature neurons
um and after 200 hours you could see
really relatively stable
neurite network under these conditions
which was all very pleasing
just to show you briefly what this looks
like in videos so this is a video
now of the
neurites differentiating so changing
into this elongated neuronal phenotype
and this is the corresponding
quantification these
uh measurements were made using an
intersite zoom lifestyle imager
which applies an algorithm to look for
long thin structures which in this case
then labels magenta
and then it quantifies the total length
the number of branch points
of these uh neurites and that's the data
which is shown in the graphic
so hopefully that's clear okay
now this is where it got interesting
when we continued to monitor these cells
what we
noticed was after about 300 hours in
culture
a number of the wells we began to see
this deterioration and the drop off
in the total neurite length and i've
separated these wells out and
color coded them red so seven of the 24
wells we began to see this
this deterioration phenotype which we
weren't expecting
when we reviewed and looked at those
images and reanalyzed them for
confluence as well as neurite length
it was very clear that there was a
strong correlation between
the drop-off in neurites and this
increase in cell confluence
and it didn't take us long to by
retrospective analysis of the images
to verify that the reason why in the
subset of these wells we saw this
unstable neuron network
was because the non-terminal internally
differentiated precursors which were
relatively few and far between
had begun to proliferate and dominate
the culture
so we we throughout the course of the
assay had the ability to understand what
was going on so just to reflect on that
um example in this case continuous lyso
analysis provided us with two things one
was
a better biological insight than we feel
we would have had by an endpoint
approach
and secondly was a greater productivity
our real-time observation and management
measurement i'm sorry gave us a
verification of cell health and
morphology throughout the study
all of our measurements were made from
living non-perturbed cells we didn't
require to fix or stain or wash them
at all times understood the time course
of the neuro outgrowth and stabilization
and we could troubleshoot to identify
this precursor proliferation
complication with regards to
productivity
all of the images were automatically
taken by the inky site and automatically
analyzed so with no overhead to the
researcher
i showed you data from the 24 control
wells in this study
we took 78 time point measurements
equating to
just under 1900 data points these wells
uh took up no more than half a million
total sales which given these are
relatively expensive and pressure sales
was
an acceptable cost to us and we didn't
require to purchase any labeling
antibodies for the experiments
and importantly the all of the
measurements were non-exhaustive so the
cells were still viable at the end of
all this to do follow-on studies for
example things like immune scientific
chemistry
okay so let's think about the second
example this is slightly different
so um this is an example where
we assembled a co-culture assay to look
at
immune cell killing of adherent tumor
cells for an immuno oncology project
so briefly what we did is we created a
co-culture with ovarian cancer cells
with human peripheral blood blood
mononuclear cells pvmcs
as the effector cells we first labelled
the nuclei of the ovarian cancer cells
with
a nuclear targeted red fluorescent
protein
so that we could quantify the
cancer cells in their own right we
duplex this with a measurement of
apoptosis
using a fluorescent caspase-37 substrate
which
only fluoresces when cells begin to
express an active
caspase enzyme we activated the co
culture with il2 cd3 to
prompt the effector cells to target the
tumor cells we measured
the tumor cell
number and the apoptotic
cell death by quantifying the red and
green channels respectively
so to begin with how was continuous
lifestyle analysis applied well from the
outset when we grew these sculp3 target
cells
in six well plates we did the
transfection with the
uh knock light red lentivirus construct
at that point we didn't know what the
optimal concentration moi
of lentivirus to use so we did a simple
matrix experiment
where we used a range of different mois
in the absence and presence of polybrine
what you can see from this analysis in
the the right half of this
slide is the optimal concentration with
moi6
plus polybrine and after two days we saw
a high
infection rate and the cells the image
on the bottom left hand side
shows that roughly 70 to 80 percent of
these cells were expressing the the
nuclear targeted rfp
we then took these cells we continue
continued
to monitor them we put them into a t175
flask to bolt them
up and this now shows uh lifestyle
analysis
of the cells in this t flask and what
you can see here is the growth curve for
these cells
and an image taken at 100 hours showing
that now in the presence of the
pure mice and selecting antibiotic for
eliminating cells not expressing the rfp
we could purify the cell population
so we then progressed with this purified
cell population into plating these cells
in preparation for our co-culture assay
so we worked on 96 well plates and our
initial target
by seeding the skull cells at 2 000
cells per well
was uh to bring about roughly twenty
percent confluence
twenty percent area occupancy across
this plate
the data on the bottom left hand side of
this slide
shows we did a reasonably good job here
on average we had 18
confluence with relatively little
variance from
uh one well to the next and this sd
value of 2
was considered a good starting point and
you can see the image of those
healthy happy stocks resales on the
upper right hand panel
we then added the pbmcs so
we required 8 000 cells for well for
this experiment
and the yellow arrow highlights
uh one of these is this very small round
bright high contrast
cell contrasting obviously with the
larger red nucleated uh
skull three cells so the continuous y
cell analysis was used
basically to qc this plate before and
after the addition
of the effector cells
so moving on to the assay itself so
what you see here now is the continuous
monitoring of these cultures for a
further seven day period
and the top left-hand panel is the
microplate view so this analysis is done
in real time so you don't have to wait
to the end of seven days to
see the outcome of the experiment you're
watching what happens as time goes by
the parameter on the y-axis is the
number of red objects so the number of
living scof3 cells in the culture
and the controls are shown in the pink
and you can see
that as the skull cells proliferate over
time
after about 120 hours they are fully
confident
in the presence of pvmcs alone you see
no effect on the ability of the scots
resales to
proliferate but if you activate those
pvmcs with il2 cd3
which is now the blue line in the panel
on the top right
you can see that the cells stop
proliferating at around about 60 hours
and the cell number starts to
decrease as the effector cells start to
kill
the target cells if we look at the
green channel to monitor the
appearance of apoptotic skull 3 cells
in the control so the pink and the dark
blue
we saw little or no apoptosis up to
about 100 hours
after that as the cultures began to get
over confluent you start to see
some dying cells but a little
in the way of comparison with what you
see with the activated
bbmc so in the il-2cd3 group in the dark
blue
around about 60 hours we start to see
the appearance of
apoptotic tumor cells we can really
verify that that's happening by
inspecting the movie so this now shows a
movie
of these cells the red cells of the
tumor cells and you see the very highly
motile
pvmcs and in a moment you'll see one
particularly large
cell begins to degranulate having been
attacked by these tumor cells there it
goes
and then it glows green as the cascade
substrate
is cleaved and the fluorophore binds to
the dna
so we have a very visual method of
verifying uh
what we're trying to measure
okay and then finally for this story uh
we can do this at a scale
i show a full plate study here with inky
site zoom you could do actually six
plates and you could do six three eight
four world plates but the example here
is
four times 96 well plates this in fact
was an antibody dependent cell killing
assay
where we were looking to test the effect
of herceptin and
accepting via similars on uh
pvmc killing of tumor cells
the important values for the the
industrialists or the screeners in the
audience are
these play qcs their prime parameters
measured from the high and low controls
which were all in excess of 0.6
illustrating highly precise and robust
screening assays we required only a
small number of cells for the entire
study with 3 million pbmcs for the
entire study
and and i just show you one
representative concentration response
curve here for
accepting to illustrate how this
approach can be turned at scale
into robust quantitative pharmacology
okay and so just reflect on that example
too
so really similar high-level messages of
the value of the approach
biological insights and enhanced
productivity
we could monitor the full time course
using a direct readout so in this case
target cell death
throughout the course of this assay we
can multiplex that with the apoptosis
readout
and the cell morphology analysis to
really build confidence in the signals
that we were measuring
the time-lapse movies verify
certain physical interactions between
target effector cells and really
support and add credibility to the
quantified data
as with the previous example all of the
images were taken and analyzed
automatically by the inky site system
hopefully i showed you how we could
streamline some of the reagent and assay
build
using this continuous lifestyle analysis
approach
in the assay itself we had four 96 well
plates with two metric tricks and 64
time points so we analyze 49 000 data
points
in this study and again in similar ways
to that which i showed you before
the cells remain viable throughout the
experiment
for follow-on studies so you could lift
them to do flow cytometry analysis
or you could sample supernatants to
measure cytokines for example using
arises
okay so that's the story just to
wrap up i showed you to begin with
how the cellular research landscape is
changing and researchers are moving
towards more complex models
where cells become more precious and
dynamic
entities i uh hopefully showed you how
developments in continuous live cell
analysis
are well aligned to the new requirements
presented by these advanced cell models
the uh continuous lifestyle imaging
methods
i showed you provide both valuable
biological insight as well as enhanced
productivity
and this can be done at scale and across
a range of different cellular workflows
my concluding statement is that
continuous lifestyle imaging and
analysis
is strongly emerging as a tool for a
powerful tool for the cell biologist
particularly for those of you that are
working with or considering working with
more
advanced cell systems so on that note
i will finish up i'll hand back to tim
who will
uh facilitate the question and answer
session thank you
great thanks dale thanks for a really
great overview for how
live cell imaging and analysis can be
used across a range of different cell
workflows from
characterizing cells and culture to
seeing manipulated and modified cells
and also in real time functional assays
but before we jump into the qc session
i'd just like to draw your attention to
the handouts section of the webinar
toolbar
where you can now download a copy of the
slides used in today's presentation so
if you take a look at the quick snapshot
that i've taken off the toolbar here
on the right hand side of the slide
hopefully you can recognize that in your
webinar toolbar
click on it and get access to all of the
slides from today's presentation
we will also be sharing with you an
email with links to
a white paper that expands on the
content and themes covered in today's
session
and a full recording of the webcast in
addition we will provide links to
publications
showing how life cell imaging and
analysis has been used in labs around
the world
to drive research in oncology immunology
neuroscience
and many other disciplines as well we
will also provide a link to the select
science website where you can access
independent reviews and customer
testimonials for all of the live cell
imaging technologies discussed here
today
okay so at this point i'd like to open
the floor to a q a session i can see a
number of questions are already coming
in from the audience here
uh so please continue to provide your
questions for down on the team by the
question box
uh in the webinar toolbar and we'll
continue to address them for you
so looking at what we've got here at the
moment um we've got a question from
carter uh so this
is a question about the t-cell killing
essay so why start at 20
confluence for short-term assay like
adcc
wouldn't you want more targeted cells so
that you have a denser image
especially if you are anticipating the
lost type of cells by affected cell
killing so
i guess this is a combination of
proliferation so there
yeah that's a that's a great question
and
it's perfectly reasonable standpoint we
have
taken the view of building our uh assays
to grow cells from lower confluence and
look for
effects on proliferation as well as the
appearance of dead cells but
absolutely you could equally set these
cells up
at a much higher confluence and look for
a reduction
in cell number and an appearance of
apoptotic cells
the only downside i can think of that
approach is
if the killing time
course is slow then potentially you will
overwhelm the cell cultures when when
they reach confluence before
you see any killing but i i have to
agree with the
the suggestion that potentially you
could do
a particularly for adcc where we know
that the killing profile
can be relatively uh relatively quick
but you could certainly um and and in
this case also the skull
iii cells are not so precious in as much
as that they're an immortalized cell
line
you could certainly use a higher cell
number to begin with so yeah that's a
great comment thank you
okay i've got a question here from susan
i like your example of neuronal
different differentiation
can you provide some other examples of
the use of lifestyle analysis to monitor
cell manipulations
okay thank you susan yeah that's that's
a great question um
i just uh picked two examples for today
but yes there are
certainly others off the top of my head
a couple that i can think of
we recently did a study with human
monocytes where we took monocytes and we
use differentiation
or two different differentiation
protocols to
induce the macrophy macrophage phenotype
so we
differentiated cells into m1 and m2
macrophages where we could verify that
the
difference in in cell morphology using
continuous lifestyle analysis
and then we use those self-same cells to
do
um real-time chemotaxis assays so that
that was
i think a nice example where life cell
analysis was used through the cell
husbandry
through to the the kinetic assay
another slightly different uh example i
can think of
is uh clonal dilution where
we did some experiments to
try to generate truly clonal cell lines
so
we seeded them out at very low density
on plates so typically less than
half a cell per well and then look for
the emergence of
colonies over time so
that was a a nice way again where
you could use the ability to review
historic data
and couple them to
later time points to really wind back to
see when
healthy colonies emerge that they really
truly form from a single
cell so hopefully those two examples are
helpful thank you thank you
a question here from kylie
could we take your adcc protocol for
ic50 calculation
yes yes we could yes i somewhat glossed
over the
the pharmacology that that came out at
the end of that but we have routinely
been
using that uh protocol to test
herceptin biosimilars for example we've
similar assay
in suspension cells where we've been
looking at rituximab and ritoximab
biosimilars where we've been doing full
quantitative
ic50 biology for uh for
decision making and and release and
potency assays
in the uh biosimilars fields so
absolutely these types of assays very
much lend themselves to full
quantitative biology okay i've got a
nice question here from peggy
do you change the media during the
open-ended experiments
yeah yeah thank you peggy yes i glossed
over that detail but
certainly if i if i take something like
the neurite uh
the neuronal differentiation protocol
where i showed you
data running out for you know a couple
of weeks then absolutely it's essential
to
to replace some of the media we
typically try not to
or i would say wash the plate and remove
the entire media we may replace
say 70 percent of the media every you
know third or fourth day
um it's interesting sometimes in the
data you can actually
see the proliferating cells you can see
they begin to decrease in their
proliferative rate as they exhaust the
nutrients of the media
and and the buildup of toxic metabolites
occurs
and then you know that it's a good time
to re-feed them and when you re-feed
them
they will start to look more healthy and
and
start to proliferate more rapidly so you
can use the data to really help
drive your refeeding paradigms
uh just you know just to add to that on
a couple of the movies i showed you
you may have noticed that they you don't
necessarily
always see the exact field of view on
some of the plastic and that's because
the plate will have been taken out of
the the inky site taken out of the
incubator for refeeding and then
repositioned
in order to continue the analysis
okay so a question from richard here
in our live cell imaging experiments
cells frequently change morphology upon
drug treatment
the algorithm often cannot be optimized
for untreated and treated morphologies
for an accurate representation of
confluency
what do you suggest as a solution so it
might be interesting to talk about nut
glides
yeah um and some other labeling
strategies yeah
yeah thank you richard that's uh again
it's a complication that i guess many
imaging or analytical methods faces the
the range of different phenotypes that
you see which particularly when you
start to work
work with unknown chemicals and
and you can see all sorts of different
things as tim alluded to there
one of the reasons why we introduced
these nuclear targeting
rfps is so that we can do true cell
counts so even if the even if the cell
morphology
looks really different to your control
cells and
and presents challenges for phase
contrast
confluence algorithm you should still be
able to count the number of viable cells
you can do a true kinetic
count over time we offer the
solution those those reagents are
commercially available so the nuclides
can be introduced either using a
lentivirus to make stable cell lines in
the t cell killing example i showed you
or you can use a bacula virus as a
transient transfection method
um if you want to you know look at a
range of different cell types that's a
viable and economical way to proceed so
i would recommend cell counting
but your comment about the differences
in cell morphology
and the challenges for the confluence
algorithm is very well made and
understood so thank you
okay i think we've got time for just one
more during this session a question from
david
uh what are your recommendations for
trying to validate the cell confluence
assay
as far as accuracy is concerned what
would you use
as a reference standard
oh now there's a there's an interesting
question
so if if if by that you mean
do you know how how can we verify that
the
the change in cell number
is accurately reported by
the change in confluence then hopefully
my answer to the previous question
to do true cell county with nuclear
labeling is one
one approach we have validated
uh by correlating our
values against other cell counting
methods so traditional cell counting
methods or
some luminescence uh or mtt assays
we've used other methods to verify
the confluence algorithm
but you know again from a high level
view my perspective is so much about
biology
is is measuring differences in treatment
groups and and the nice thing is is that
you you have enough capacity and
bandwidth here to
to run controls and to compare effects
you know a versus effect b and vehicle
treated controls
to make sure that it's the differences
that you're focusing on
and not to get too obsessed by the
absolute values
great okay so i think in the interest of
time here we need to draw a close to
this session but it's really great to
see the
amount of audience engagement here we
continue to get questions in
so we will of course be responding to
all the questions we receive today
and invite you to continue this
conversation by mailing us
at the email address you see now on your
screen communications at
smbio.com it'll be a pleasure to
continue to talk with you
so it is left to me today now to thank
you all for your attendance today
um as you log out the webinar you will
be provided with a feedback survey so
please do fill this in as it helps us
tailor these events for you
we hope that you found this webinar
thought provoking and the content useful
and you take the opportunity to explore
the use of lifestyle imaging and
analysis for your research and cell
workflows
so please stay tuned to our social media
channels like linkedin and facebook
for information around the next webinar
in our series where we will see you next